[Musique]
Charlotte, je voudrais vous approuver pour
être le prochain président des États-
Unis, c'est la secrétaire d'État qui
nous regarde.
Je la connais un peu.
pour parler avec toi
avec moi je ne peux pas me débarrasser de ce sentiment que
nous nous connaissons je suis Fred Karski
ouais qu'est-ce que tu fais ces jours-ci je suis
journaliste tu es un grand écrivain
tu dois juste atténuer un peu
un peu mais ce journalisme est mort aujourd'hui cette
écriture est vraiment bonne amener quelqu'un
comme ça dans l'équipe était un peu
imprudent
c'est une prescription pour l'anxiété
pour toi, je devrais en quelque sorte mieux te connaître
quel est leur livre préféré quand j'étais enfant Le
lapin de velours a très bien dû
être aimé par les rochers moments
embarrassants qu'ils ne gênent pas si facilement Je ne sais pas
non plus vraiment quel est ton f  position sexuelle préférée rendez-vous
normal je
veux dire qui veut me suivre à travers le
monde et j'espère avoir cinq minutes pour être
affectueux une chose que
nous avons en fait presque mourir nous devons
vous déplacer Merci agent eux grandi
près de mes étudiants je serais
ravi d'habiller un ami pour ce soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
politicien Je voulais écrire pour vous le
public ne vous acceptera jamais tous les deux
il n'y a aucun moyen que
vous travailliez c'est une jolie femme mais c'est
Richard Gere tu es Julia Roberts I
n'essayez jamais vraiment de l'atténuer et
vous ne savez pas vous faire risquer
[Musique]
vous